oh we had a look at this idea of regions
which are just when you have an
inequality right inequalities like this
we are used to dealing with inequalities
that are one-dimensional on a number
line because a wide is one-dimensional
to have a region which by the babe you
can tell defines a 2d space that's what
you've got well when you got two
variables two-dimensional inequalities
okay
so that's all we moved into now we're
going to look at today is where you've
got more than one region you want to
combine them in a particular way and as
you'll see there are two ways to combine
the we'll explore each let's just go
back to what we think about with 2d
first though so minus 1 is less than
equal to X which is less than 3 ok like
I said before we are familiar with this
enough now but you can literally see
what this is going to be before I draw
it right let's go ahead and draw it so
you put your build circle you hollow
circle and then you have everything in
between no dramas okay this is fine this
is great how about just really call your
mind to the fact that this is really an
abbreviation right this is this one set
of inequalities is really shorthand for
- okay it's shorthand for X is gonna
start from here and then you can be
greater than that so X is greater than
or equal to negative 1 right and at the
same time right so I would use the word
and at the same time X must be less than
3 ok so what does this look like let's
just quickly draw because both of these
are their only inequality and we can
represent each of them separately so if
we were to do X is less than which like
Rain Man or equal to minus 1 you've got
your own - one of your three is still
there now what I'm gonna do is these two
separate inequalities I'm going to draw
beneath the number line right because
they're not what I actually want like
I'm going to draw this
first one over here and goes on words
because there's nothing stopping it and
then you've got this guy which is going
from here to the left and you're ever
stopping you
so what we say this what we mean is
where did these two things overlap when
they coincide where are they both
simultaneously true what that is of X
can satisfy this and this at the same
time so values like zero and one and two
and all of the ones in between so
therefore when you take this right you
map the overlap of these two perceptions
you map them onto your number line just
like you did before
okay so I want both of them I want both
of them can you see that over here even
though I've got one of them I know the
other so that's why it's excluded from
my actual number line path and in the
same way over here I have one of them
but not both of them some stuff okay
what we have here the word for this is
an intersection right these two y's like
I've drawn them apart from each other so
you can see see them separately right
bit hard to see two straight lines when
they're literally on top of each other
but if I could put them on top of each
other
I want the set of points where they
intersect right just like two lines you
know we're used to thinking of two lines
and they intersect at a single point
right but if the two lines are parallel
and they lie on top of one another they
intersect at an infinite number of
points right so what I've got here is
the intersection of these two points we
have a symbol for this word because it's
very long it's even longer it's the
simpler one is even shorter than one and
it's a upside down I do
you shake without a without a tail in it
okay yeah it's kind of like a like a
like a bad speed that's the symbol
that's the symbol for the intersection
of two inequalities okay
now within the course within the course
this is the only way really that you
need to worry about in terms of
combining regions okay and so I'm going
to leave that for now and we're going to
have a look at some examples in 2d space
there is one other way to combine
regions but we'll get onto after we have
this nailed and we're a bit more
comfortable so the right-hand side what
we've got a few here and I'm using this
intersection notation okay you'll see
there's more than one inequality and I'm
combining them I one where both of them
overlap where they intersect okay you'll
look at four and five anything hold on
there's only one inequality there but
the astute among you will notice there
really aren't soon it's just implied
okay so let's start let's have a go at
the first one as you know what you have
an inequality all you need to figure is
just the um the actual equivalent
equation and now we'll give you the
boundary right each one so our first
step is just to draw the boundaries and
then work out which sides were wrong
okay so let's draw y equals x and x
equals 3 and then we'll start working
colors with me all right
here my boundary lines now I think let's
see it seemed like we all with this I
think we recruit two things are actually
on these and don't worry about testing
points okay I think we can nail this Y
is greater than X Y is the subject
something critical am i above this or am
i below above right Y is greater than
greater than okay so here's the section
which is above and I'm going to just
like I did here I'm just gonna draw the
entire section region that corresponds
to that one part of it okay I've got
that now I can do this other one X is
the subject actually exit everything
that's there it's X less than so am I to
the left or to the right to the left
it's lesser than lesser then these
values over here a lesser right so
here's my X is equal to 3 and I'm going
to be less if all you've got is a pencil
you should shade as best you can so you
can distinguish between these two I'm
gonna put my lines going in different
directions so now just like we did
before
right this one one in vertical is
inequality really is where these two
inequalities overlap right so you have a
look at your all on my my cross hatching
right you can see for instance in this
section down here this triangle looking
thing I satisfy X is less than 3 but I
do not satisfy Y is greater than X so
it's out in the same way this triangle
over here it satisfies Y is greater than
X but it does not satisfy X is less than
3
so both these triangles are out okay
whereas you've got this double shaded
area over here and that's the actual
region that I'm after okay so now women
with a different color or with you know
harder shading this is the area
I really want this one up
you can see by the way color pencils are
a legitimate investments to Jersey maybe
not for your actual answer but so that
as you do your working there you trying
to make sure you see where sections
overlap this is not as easy as it gets
two straight lines as you see it will
get a little more involved but that's
available see clearly which sections
which is is really good our office done
let's have a look at this thing you can
see I've got some important points here
for instance I've got an intercept
because it's the origin I'm already
labeled good but there's another
intercept that I'm actually interested
in right yeah okay sure
it's yeah good at this point right up
here okay now at this boundary there's
two boundaries meeting so I want to know
what's happening at that particular spot
right and just like we had before we
have language for what happens to an
inequality at a particular spot it's
either going to be a field or a hollow
circle so I'm going to put a hollow
circle there and then I'm going to
decide whether I need if you fill it or
not okay what is that point what in the
corner to that point it's a simple it's
33 isn't it okay just like intercepts on
a normal graph points of intersection on
your boundary
you must label right so three three pop
your corn with on there is three three
in the region I want or is it excluded
now this is an easy example because I've
got two dotted lines here
neither of them included and I need to
have both of them included in order for
that point to be part of it so it's not
it could there's no way it can be right
this boundary doesn't include it that
battery doesn't quit it it's a hollow
circle